con una población de algo más de 30
millones de habitantes el perú una de
las tierras más bellas del mundo es el
cuarto país más grande de latinoamérica
y una de las naciones con más
biodiversidad y recursos naturales de
todo el planeta en este extenso país
andino podemos encontrar entre otros
muchos recursos naturales las mayores
reservas de plata las terceras mayores
reservas de cobre y zinc o las sextas de
oro de todo el mundo en este vídeo
hablamos de perú y fuji está visual
política
el perú sigue siendo un país pobre y aún
son muchas las carencias que sin duda
presenta su mal constitucional pero pese
a ello este país destaca entre sus
países vecinos latinoamericanos como un
ejemplo de buenas reformas y hay quien
incluso afirma que de continuar este
proceso en poco tiempo nos referiremos a
perú como una gran potencia latina tan
solo lima su capital tiene ya un
producto interior bruto 4 veces superior
al de bolivia
evolución económica
pero he registrado en la última década
la segunda mayor tasa de crecimiento
económico de toda latinoamérica en este
mismo período su pib se ha más que
duplicado la inversión ha pasado del 13%
del pib a más del 20 y el línea de
pobreza esto es el porcentaje de
personas que no tienen cubiertas las
necesidades esenciales de alimentación
abrigo educación y atención médica se ha
reducido de cotas superiores al 50% en
año 2000 al entorno del 22% hoy en día
menos de la mitad no está mal el perú es
el país que más redujo la pobreza en
américa latina en los últimos 13 años y
ojo el perú son de los países más
adinerados de toda latinoamérica e
incluso del mundo gracias anda decidida
responsabilidad en el uso del dinero
público un logro por cierto compartido
por los últimos gobiernos de ollanta
humala
alan garcía y alejandro toledo en la
deuda pública se ha reducido a menos de
la mitad desde el año 2000 y hoy supone
poco más del 20 por ciento del pib
pero cómo surgió la prosperidad de perú
o mejor dicho cómo se alcanzó semejante
consenso político en torno a la
responsabilidad presupuestaria de las
políticas pro mercado y tomamos una
medida en el que el principal
perjudicado va a ser el mes porque va a
recaudar menos y ya pues bien este es
sin duda el punto más interesante y
donde el perú nos traslada una valiosa
enseñanza hace poco en visual política
hablamos sobre el desastre de venezuela
pues bien la década de los 80 fue para
el perú aún peor veamos qué ocurre
crisis de los 80
en la década de los 70 y la pre a mitad
de los 80 los gobiernos peruanos
apostaron por impulsar la economía a
través de la inversión estatal y la
sustitución de las importaciones
limitando la compra de productos
extranjeros para lograrlo tuvieron que
pedir muchos préstamos lo que disparó la
deuda pública los resultados fueron tan
pobres que cuando el 79 se produjo la
crisis del petróleo y se ralentizó con
ello el crecimiento económico
internacional y la demanda de materias
primas el gobierno del perú comenzó a
tener tantos problemas que en 1983
suspendió pagos es decir dejó de pagar
la deuda porque se quedó sin dinero en
otras palabras el gobierno de perú
quebró a partir de ahí la cosa fue de
mal en peor y con la llegada de alan
garcía al poder en 1985 el desastre fue
ya casi total el gobierno comenzó
intervenir masivamente en la fijación de
precios y en el mercado laboral reforzó
las políticas que tenían como objetivo
sustituir las importaciones limitando
las cantidad de productos que se podían
comprar y estableciendo un arancel medio
que llegó al nivel del 66%
pero si siento que estamos haciendo una
revolución
el déficit público estaba por las nubes
y la economía informal era la norma
habitual con lo que a pesar de existir
más de 100 tributos el estado apenas
lograba recaudar impuestos y como además
había suspendido pagos y nadie le
prestaba dinero que hizo pues comencé a
imprimir más y más dinero convirtiendo
al inti en acre entonces la divisa
peruana en una moneda con prácticamente
el mismo valor que el dinero del
monopolio
por si fuese poco el narcotráfico y el
terrorismo de los grupos sendero
luminoso y el movimiento revolucionario
túpac amaru en la mera tea se
extendieron por el país causando decenas
de miles de muertos el mrt a ubican su
centro de operaciones en la zona de la
selva nororiental y busca una alianza
estratégica con las bandas de
narcotraficantes el resultado de todo
ello fue que al final de la década el
pie se había sumado un 25 por ciento el
pib per cápita se situaba en los niveles
de 1960 la inflación anual superó el 7
mil 500 por cien en 1990 y el banco
mundial reconocido a perú como una de
los países más pobres del mundo el año
85 cuánto costaba un kilito en frijoles
65 y nada más
67 ahí entró a lana cultiva con 67
comprar su equilibrio pero cuando
terminó el ala en el año 90 cuatro
costados quiero ver goles 122 mil 305 un
kilo de frijoles bueno el centro fue de
tal magnitud que el banco mundial
calcula que de no haberse producido el
pib per cápita en paridad de poder
adquisitivo del perú sería equivalente
al de países como italia
o corea del sur casi nada si os fijáis
en cierto modo la que si es similar a la
que hoy vive venezuela mucho gasto
público muchos impuestos impresión de
más y más moneda violencia y caída en el
precio de las materias primas
precisamente cuando hicimos el vídeo
sobre la crisis en venezuela muchos los
preguntasteis que haríamos para salir de
la crisis pues bien hoy vamos a ver que
hizo perú
camino a la prosperidad
y en 1990 dio comienzo un intenso plan
de reformas y estabilización económica
que prácticamente podemos decir se ha
alargado hasta nuestros días y que ha
pasado por los siguientes puntos para
frenar la inflación se sustituyó la
moneda nacional en vigor el inti una
nueva moneda el nuevo sol y se permitió
en la práctica la dolarización de la
economía la estabilidad monetaria pasó
desde ese momento a ser una prioridad
nacional se reformuló y simplificó todo
el sistema tributario suprimiendo más de
64 impuestos se reestructuró el sistema
de pensiones tomando como modelo el
sistema de capitalización chileno aunque
eso sí introduciendo numerosas mejoras
por cierto de este tema tan
controvertido hablaremos muy pronto se
puso en marcha un intenso programa de
atracción de inversión extranjera y
privatización de empresas públicas en
poco tiempo empresas como la compañía
peruana de teléfonos aeroperú o
electrolima pasaron a la competencia
privada se aprobó una estrategia de
apertura comercial que se ha traducido
en la reducción del arancel medio desde
el increíble 66% al entorno del 1 y
medio al tiempo que se han firmado
numerosos tratados de libre comercio
incluyendo uno con eeuu y otro con la
unión europea en 2002 comenzó una
paulatina
realización del poder de tal forma que
hoy la mayor parte de la inversión
pública corresponde ya a las regiones ya
los municipios y por último el punto tal
vez más destacado la apuesta por el
equilibrio presupuestario que han
mantenido todos los gobiernos desde
entonces de hecho en 1999 se aprobó la
llamada ley de prudencia y transparencia
fiscal que limita el poder discrecional
de los gobiernos para gastar más de lo
que se ingresa e introduce elementos
correctores en situaciones de déficit
público no son pocos los expertos que
afirman que ésta ha sido la ley más
importante del extremo ra el perú desde
luego gracias a ellas los operarios
públicos no resultan extraños en el perú
perú registró un superávit fiscal del 7
por ciento en el primer trimestre del
año esto como consecuencia del aumento
de los ingresos del gobierno y un
crecimiento económico sostenido es
verdad en los años 90 pero también tuvo
su lado de sombras no penséis que nos
hemos olvidado del autoritarismo de
alberto fujimori un presidente que hoy
está cumpliendo una condena de 25 años
por crímenes contra la humanidad y
delitos de corrupción
bueno como veis y aquí me refiero
especial a todos nuestros amigos
venezolanos formar que hacen las cosas
siempre hay salida
el perú hoy y mañana pero porque perú es
todavía un país pobre como decíamos al
principio son aún muchas las carencias
institucionales y los retos a los que se
enfrenta la nación andina entre ellos
podemos destacar la elevada corrupción y
la inseguridad jurídica algo que por
ejemplo podemos ver con el caso de los
escuadrones de la muerte también la
altísima delincuencia la elevada
burocracia y el riesgo de que la
industria minera conlleve los mismos
problemas de corte rentista que sufre
chile por no olvidar el gran contraste
en el nivel de vida que existe entre las
diferentes regiones precisamente el
pasado 5 de junio de 2016 se celebró la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales por la que fue elegido
pedro pablo kuczynski como el nuevo
presidente de la república estas
elecciones fueron por cierto las más
reñidas de la historia y kuczynski se
impuso a su adversaria keiko fujimori
hija de alberto fujimori por poco más de
40 mil votos en tres objetivos
anunciados por kuczynski está continuar
la agenda de impulso a la competitividad
y a la apertura comercial así por
ejemplo ha prometido reducir al 10 por
ciento el impuesto sobre beneficios para
las pymes para las pequeñas y medianas
empresas combatir la burocracia
eliminando de forma
y regulaciones necesarias y apostar para
consolidar el proyecto de integración
conocido como alianza el pacífico si
cuché se consigue a pesar de la relativa
debilidad política a la que se enfrenta
con un congreso no precisamente amigo
mantener el timón y combatir los
problemas que afectan al perú estoy
convencido de que el crecimiento de la
nación andina continuará estando a la
cabeza de américa latina puede que en
pocos años pero una nación joven cuya
población de una media de edad de apenas
27 años logre emular el desarrollo de
los llamados dragones asiáticos y
transformarse en una importante potencia
que puede ser vosotros logrará pero
dejar atrás la pobreza y convertirse en
toda una potencia es kuczynski la
persona idónea para lograrlo esperamos
vuestros comentarios si os ha gustado el
vídeo darle a like y suscribiros al
canal si aún no lo habéis hecho ya hasta
la próxima amigos o como diríamos en
quechua suponen chis cama más y cuna